السادس من يونيو هو اليوم الذي تترقبه
الكويت من اجل اختيار 50 نائبا يمثلها تحت
قبه عبد الله سالم يترشح للسباق انتخابات
مجلس الامه 2003
مرشحين ومرشحه
وزاره العدل خصصت
759 لجنه انتخابيه بعدما جهزت وزاره
التربيه
وثمانيه عشره مدرسه وحولتها لمركز اقتران
يتوجه اليها نحو
794 الف ناخب وناخبه لاختيار نائب واحد في
دائرتهم المسجلين فيها
الكويت ومصلحه شعبها فوق اي اعتبار هذا
ابرز الشعارات المرشحين الذين حاولوا
التقرب من الناخبين بشعاراتهم وندواتهم
الانتخابيه التي ناقش فيها مطالب الشعبي
واسباب تاخر تحقيقها في المجالس السابقه
الا ان ترقب الاكبر يبقى على استمراريه
المجلس وعمل السلطتين التنفيذيه
والتشريعيه مع بعضهما من الكويت شاهد
المتروك العربيه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات